hello
hello
good morning
good afternoon
good evening
we're back
forgot where we were why is chat that
low oh
hello hold on let me fix this
oh that's why
uh we're gonna go right
there
hi guys
how's everybody doing
i decided to get dark souls 3.
great idea it's an amazing game
hello
why are you all yellow
why is every name yellow
oh well
but yo yo yo
what up shock ace lorenzo
oh it's a little dino what's up man
martin merka
miro
alex what's up guys
oh god okay
hope everyone's having a great day
so far today's gonna be kind of weird
cause we are
aggressively
aggressively cleaning uh the house for
family coming later today
um so yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yep yep yep
so that means i i can probably stream
tomorrow i don't really know yet we're
gonna we're gonna see what comes
tomorrow
uh but i'll be gone all weekend
yeah aggressively cleaning the house
like
i tell you your boy finally hit ssl like
two seasons ago
congrats man good for you that's awesome
what up glenn
should i play sikiro yes you should play
all of the games they're all good
nito and betta chaos
yeah we'll see where we get to today
i don't know how long i can stream for
uh
wait today's gonna be weird all right
it's gonna it's just gonna be weird
today so
bear with me where do i go from here
that looks scary
well welcome i hope you're all having a
good day
uh
what the frick
are these bones yep
that's creepy
i can't see a foot in front of you man
okay yeah i gotta go up the lad
[Music]
okay where's the ladder again
i know you guys can't see but trust me i
can't see either
yes i already died maddie
i
couldn't see
where do i go what do i do
that scared me i
you freak good day good day you look
reasonably sane
what are you doing in the catacombs
are you a cleric or something
[ __ ] patches
a cleric
no
no
no really
then i'd have no qualms telling you
there's a fine stash of treasure right
down that hole i found it first but well
we're friends now we'll get through it
boy man in any case have a look have a
look it'll shimmer you blind why'd they
only let you play nine holes on the
fourth
one that's weird
should i just kill him
then
now
take a closer look
now let's do it
oh patches
this is what i do my friend
this is what i do
[Laughter]
[Music]
my god
okay what's even down here is it even
that bad
i hear scary things
wait what's a skull lantern
what's that
can i equip it
no
is it like a helmet
[Music]
where do i where do i equip the helmet
is it like one of these like is it a
weapon
what oh
aha
i did it
i'm very smart as you can see
what the heck is this
you're no hollow are you
thank goodness please be careful a
cypher there were two face hollows not
far from here they were once brave
knights my former escorts
who would let such strong spirits be
hollowed so
heavens
is there nothing
nothing at all to be done
i can murder them for you if you wish
ah
wait it's the fat guys
from up top
they went hollow
i'm gonna roll off some type of edge
oh i love it yeah
okay
that was pain
you're dead
where's the other fat guy
wasn't there three of
them i don't know why i'm calling them
fat they just seem fat
okay i don't see another one let me go
talk to her again
dude this lantern helps a lot
like a ton
you banished those two hollows did you
it didn't leaves me to think of the
trouble my failings have caused i'm
certain that both vince and nico are
grateful to you
thank you so very much
here
these belonged to them
you deserve them more than i
i don't want that i am certain that both
vince and nico are grateful to you
thank you so very much
you're welcome
okay bye
enjoy sitting in a dark ass cave
surrounded by skeletons
what of what an odd existence
okay
not what i was expecting
at all
i ain't gonna cap on a stack with you
ew
white tight knight chunk
i don't know if i've seen that yet
feel up a little bittle
other one's kind of a traitor
all right okay
did i just hear a bonfire light up
i swear i heard the the audio cue for
that
excellent
you think i haven't played these games
before
you're wrong
oh this is where i've been
wait
is this where i've been
yeah
well okay
i did just get kicked down a hole i'm
just trying to get out of the hole
that's right
that's right
so
i'm gonna kindle this actually i don't
even know if i'm i can't tell if i'm
hollow or not
wait it tells me yeah i don't have
humanity okay
so
use two
let's kindle this [ __ ]
she'll she'll go to the undead church
that's what i thought
that makes sense
that makes sense
kendall
now we'll have ten
augers
if i see patches should i just kill him
i'm sure he says something like
how did you get out of there
can i talk to you oh
you
i
well
let's just calm down
talk about things i did you wrong but i
didn't mean it
these
temptations
they can
well
overcome me you know what i mean don't
you
please
forgive me you and me we're jolly undead
outcasts jolly cooperation
uh
yeah
how brilliant a second chance
wonderful
i had a feeling you'd understand i did
but uh
if i were in your shoes
thank you shannon who knows what i might
have done
but
now we're friends again
hey
[Laughter]
god
okay
i want to kill him
okay i won't kill him though
i know i should but i won't
oh my god
a skelly dog
where does this go
uh you mean the golden cleric cypher we
did kill him
because he's mean
ow
hello
okay
okay
okay i couldn't even move
i got staggered by the arrow
jesus
[Music]
wow my god
it's got annihilated by the arrow
patches is still here
spawn killing area
upswing it
okay
yep totally free acupuncture
i'm definitely looking for acupuncture
god they sound so creepy bro
oh
oh god
i hate this
okay
what the
did he come from behind
the heck
you missed
the noise they make when they die is so
cool
i couldn't see him at all
oh you're just a big boy
who has the ability to kick
understood
no kidding they're lurking
i'm scared
yeah the giant flashbacks no kidding
metal
stupid idiot boy you didn't fall that
far
okay these guys are crazy
okay
there we go
where is the bonfire
i no see bonfire
down here
yeah i died
so i can't get invaded
it's like they want you to be dead
oh boy
this is a horror game
it it just is a horror game
like that that is just scary
effigy shield that sounds cool
this is dark souls 1
what's up m7
this is bloodborne
okay i'm startled and scared but we're
gonna we're gonna take the plunge we're
gonna go for it
boom
[Applause]
sometimes you just gotta take
you just gotta go for it
you know
you just gotta be a little scared you
gotta go for it
all right
stop
yeah that plunging attack was lit
it was an insta kill
stay
there's three of them
stay
good
excellent
pro tip don't die thank you
what up i did not need to take that
ladder did i
whoa what is that
it looks like the great tree
i like this
actually looks like the great tree from
elden ring
it's over here why is there a path here
okay
that's the er tree did leondell get
flooded
it's definitely not the urgery it looks
a lot like it though
there's a bonfire behind you in here
come here
you can probably upgrade
yeah is it the great tree the crucible
tree
i can't be
ah i'm going back you guys said there
was a bonfire near here
would you say is the most fun build in
elden ring not the most powerful but the
most fun to play
um i really like strength builds
i've always find them a lot a lot of fun
so go for that if you want
am i going the right way
i don't remember a bonfire around here
am i tripping balls
or do i gotta kill those doggies
go to the cave okay everything's a cave
way way
back go back down the ladder
am i getting trolled
what is happening
okay
i'm getting trolled right
into the hole on the right
what hole
here
can you not see it no
i don't
for real for real
that looks like death
the whole
i don't know what you're talking about
go back down that path and there's a
cave on the right
i was going this way and then you all
said turn around
so right here
down there
ow
the animation
i'm scared to drop down there that looks
like death
well i would like the bonfire to have
more than five
so i just need to keep going you guys
are so [ __ ] confusing
holy crap
half of you were saying to go back to
the dogs
okay that hurt
okay
what the [ __ ]
i did get you baited
wow
did that skeleton morph out of the wall
[Music]
where was there at any point
a [ __ ] bonfire
i just want to murder him okay
nice
i'm over it
you guys suck
you guys are bad at giving directions
you're bad at it
you just missed it that sucks
just terrible
yum yum yum yum yum yum
oh i know i went past it now
[Applause]
nope
i'm not going back
i'm defying y'all now
ew
okay they're chilling over there
it's a bunch of pinwheels
whoa
what the heck
ew
oh my god
that is terrifying
[Applause]
okay we're kind of owning right there
whoa
kill the babies i
no
is this neato i think
oh i gotta drop down don't i
[Music]
i just take a bunch of damage right off
the rip of this boss
dang
they indefinitely respond so there's no
point in killing them
gross
all right what's the uh what's the trick
to this guy
oh
hit him with sword
i don't know what he's doing
gross
i don't have hamil's armor
okay
what
this is my fault if i die
i mean obviously
it's never not my fault
this is really annoying okay
it was going so well
i think if i just stayed close and
started hacking away would have been
fine
roll when you hear scream just stay
under him
yeah if i just stayed close and just
kept hitting him i think we would have
been fine
yeah and he kills his own mobs
so that's like that's fine
i said this bonfire saves
20 seconds
okay i just i don't want to deal with it
i don't have the humanity to
okay
you know is the boss
i mean no [ __ ] he's the uh lord of death
right death and disease
don't go back into the room there are
scary skellies
don't go back
of room okay
don't go back of the room
yes mommy
okay the damage
in this area
is a lot or does my armor suck
i think my armor sucks
you're fine right over there
[Applause]
don't disrespect the black leather
that's exactly what i'm doing
howie
oh god
is there any way to take
not damage
by falling
you almost died
yeah that wasn't ideal but here we are
oh
okay this is where we run away right
yes
okay
that went well
why does he take off his clothes before
he does
what the heck
maddie told me not to go back here but
here we are doing exactly that
you probably meant during the boss fight
he's so nerfed i don't think they've
touched this game in 10 years bro
nice guys good stuff um
i want a level endurance so i can have
like better armor
without like fat rolling
so
we got neato's vessel
should we try four kings again
oh you meant lore wise
he's nerfed lore wise
i don't know that
just here
do i have any uh
fire keeper souls
no
uh let's go see if we can upgrade with
andre
four kings yeah we should do that next
where do i get i get in anor londo
apple's armor
i mean what if i
i have like good armor that's better
than what i'm wearing
[Music]
like elite night armor i would like to
wear this
that's not a bad roll
yeah it's like medium roll that's fine
well hello again i know you seem to be
doing all right need
i do um
[Music]
wait it says oh i only have three out of
four
okay
um
should i go buy from the giant i'll be
seeing you then be careful
i might try that
[Music]
am i about to go to an area where i'm
going to be fine
i should buy them um
what's the chamber of the princess
i'm just gonna warp
ah
yeah this is where we want to be yeah
perfect
we
it's like dark souls 3 where there's
just like an entrance on the right side
over here
started playing dark souls 2 yesterday
and it's a lot better than you expected
i'm gonna start that whenever we finish
this so
i never beat it
so i'm excited
illusionary wall
that one
let's see
it's so cool that the layout of this
place is pretty much exactly the same as
it is in dark souls 3. i know it's the
same area but it's cool that they did
that
giant should be over here yep i can hear
him
i've heard dark souls 2 is not in the
same world
my boy
who are
your weapons
yes uh let me purchase a twinkle tip
please thank you
okay
reinforce
is there any reason for me to reinforce
my shield
excellent
so is it fully upgraded is that what i
just said i wasn't paying attention
[Music]
yeah i don't even see it
or can he just not do it
shiny shiny
get shiny from duke
forge weapons
make
shiny more happy
excellent
excellent
modify equipment
i can't really do that can i reinforce
armor
that i should do yeah
i think i'll be fine with this this
armor
guiding me
let's do this
y'all can call it a waste that's fine
yes sir
let's go back
shiny shiny
metal hates dark souls 2
i never finished it
i remember being frustrated with it so i
completely stopped playing it it's over
here
so
i don't think we're gonna need that
right now
apparently nothing
why can't armor be upgraded in elden
ring they just didn't add that in i
don't know why
seen the video of someone buffing the
moon veil
yikes
a weapon that already does not need to
be buffed
would have over complicated things the
game's already complicated enough just
make it more complicated
okay so we were
how are we going through that area were
we just dying in firelink shrine and
going to four kings
i think we were
we should be totally good
let's do it
where's my armor so loud entirely
you know what would be cool is if we
could upgrade torrent in elden ring
i feel like they did torrent dirty
like he's not even that important he's
just a horse
where he could be a lot cooler than he
is
but maybe that's something they add in
later you know
yeah i like torrent
but i feel like they could have done
more with them
imagine if you give torrent like
different armor
no this isn't negan
torrent summoning makes no sense why
if we couldn't summon torrent that would
just make the game annoying
[Music]
inconsistent if he starts running or not
i don't i don't know what that means
that doesn't make any sense
like when you
summon him and he
is running with you or not
you just have to be at full sprint
and then he will run with you
that is such a weird gripe
okay let's see if we can beat them
i don't have the ring on
do i not have to go
why are you guys asking me stuff
like i don't know
what you're talking about when you say
like drained
like what area
like i don't know what you're talking
about
okay
i didn't rest it fire like either
he doesn't if the terrain is uneven i
mean that's just part of like it being a
video game
you're not standing on an even surface
then
it doesn't work
i don't know that's a weird gripe i get
what you're saying though that sometimes
he just doesn't come out that's never
like gotten me killed a single time so i
don't even think of it
man i am putting on havel's ring
until we get there
this is my
goal
okay like like where can i run though
like i know i drain the area but where
is it like possible to run now
down there
oh that looks like death
yeah i already did that hamster
i just don't know where i can run that
would take me to where i want to go
other than over here
now
oh
i already don't like this area
why am i here
the other way was so much easier
oh my god
it's right there i'm i'm just dumb
are they gonna leave me alone to put on
the ring
of course not
please don't hit a side thank you
ah
this is already going horribly bad
bum
good nice close spawn
nice
stay over there stay over there
stop it
it's like the elden stars
there we go
it's so dark
hello
hello oh here we go
stop running away
i hate that
this takes so long man
that's not good
did that go right through him
stick
oh you're so far away come here
thank you
is there any way to dodge that
that's just bad rng
okay
one more
come come come
why am i trying to dodge
yeah move
i just didn't hit
one more
okay
and why is it called four kings when i
killed five
or did i only kill four i can't count
bequeath lord soul shard
nice
gg easy
gg no re
rust
first try
actually first try
uh if i didn't fall
and die
that was an accident i didn't know i
didn't have the ring on
okay
okay
let me take the stupid ring off
and put you on augers
oh also can i use these uh souls for
souls
like i know i have to put these in the
the lord vessel right or no i don't
actually have them that i can pop them
okay never mind
scratch what i was saying uh ignore it
yeah i put the lord vessel down
didn't in the original souls
didn't you have to pop one at a time
still kind of fat rolling okay
it's a mid roll
oh hello there hey mummy safe oh and uh
if by chance you've had a change of
hearts
i'll be pleased to assist you by sharing
my spells
yeah wonderful i'm sure that you know
they'll be of some use probably the
weapon i'm using is the best
a flame from the great swamp
now you're a fully fledged pyromancer
well let's get started right now
i like his voice
[Music]
okay i'll come back goodbye then be safe
friend
where's uh where's fatty is he over here
big chilling
there he is
oh you again
me uh
i've become separated from a lady i've
scoured near and far
but no sight of her
i know where she is i'm a lady
to think i swore to protect you with my
life
do i just not tell him that's hilarious
okay
kill him
okay
no
this can't be
it can't end like this
little w get annihilated idiot okay
where do we go now
what do we do i went to catacombs i went
to four kings
uh
yeah where do i go now
dude i freaking
gasp that guy wasn't even
[Music]
close lava land oh yeah
lost izalith that chaos all right let's
go
is
let's just go here
archives we already win archives
we already went there
let me offer my humanity
i do two ha oh i have to pop them that's
right
we already went archives why are y'all
telling me that
should i pop these twins as well
i'm just popping them all i don't care
if y'all get mad y'all get mad
humanity
14.
how many did i give her before
rank gained
okay i don't know
we already we just killed grave lord
nedo
okay i'll uh keep a lookout for
humanities
i think i have i killed seath i killed
nito and i killed uh four kings
last one's better chaos yeah
must be
let's get it
okay so we lowered the lava
you have to give them before the bed of
chaos to save him otherwise his brain
gets eaten by the sun bugs
oh
um
can i progress through the area without
killing the bed of chaos
and then we can come back
are there humanities that i can gain
here
oh we can go to dlc as well
okay
i'll progress
we'll kill the first boss
and then uh we'll come back
oh hello
you're bad at this game kid
okay what is kurt
no you can't
why are people telling me i can then
i'm gonna believe the girl that has like
2 000 hours in this game
i just go down there but i can survive
that fall
oh yeah that's that weird worm
hello
you can go up to centipede demon and
then you have to go save him so i can
kill that boss yeah
owned
artorias is the dlc boss right you're
one of them
these guys suck
okay
cool this game is so strange compared to
elden ring right it's kind of weird
i'll i dig it though
i still definitely dig it
sanctuary guardian
that's that lion right
if i remember right there's a bonfire
behind this worm yeah oh there it's it's
literally right [ __ ] there okay
ew
[Music]
there it is
[Music]
i don't remember the sanctuary garden
isn't it that like white flying lion
that has to be
that this sounds perfect
all right
let's get it
look at all these nerds
they look like little turds coming right
at me
oh you are large
just a tourist demon out just out here
you actually fit the script very well
hello
i regret saying hi to you you suck
bye
okay
yo
you're dead
you're dead
what's over here
i'm gonna do this first
demon fire sage
why does this look just like an asylum
demon
but on fire
how could he possibly be weak to fire
now
stop running for me fatty
okay that was easy
oh i got humanity have i just
trivialized this game with this weapon
just totally trivialized it
should i should i not continue on like
where
where can i stop
it's like right outside better chaos
i got the easy mode with this huh
uh
the hole should i go in the hole
should i put it in the hole
i am very open
i can see them hovering
oh
uh
oh
a little shortcut
a little shortcut ski doodle
okay or actually i'm just go here
nice see
let's go right here
and give her the humanity i found
like how there's music here
how many did i get
i got juan
i can probably level two
um
let's use these
i only have one
okie dokie artichoke
sit up
i just keep leveling endurance because i
don't know
why not
stamina seems way more important in this
game than it did in um in elden ring
ellen ring did not seem like to give a
[ __ ] about stamina
[Music]
okay
uh i don't know what centipede demon is
but i'm just gonna continue
wait that's where i came
let me put that back up
okay
wait this is where i came from
but i can drop down yeah
this way
oh
you can summon solaire jolly cooperation
i like that
i'm not gonna get that item
was that a cricket
a sunlight metal
who's dying down there
what's going on
some contraption
what's happening
this is where you can open the shortcut
after you give the lady your humanity
these are the bugs you have to kill to
save solaire
what's up retro how are you
okay
oh that's the covenant door
okay
um where should i go now
it wouldn't let me open the door
i should do dlc okay
let's do it
i should just go this way
wait but i fell
that's fine
so we'll go to the dlc we'll farm
humanities we'll give them to
the lady
will be golden
can i get a poggers chat
easy dubs easy dubs
i know you don't really say poggers on
youtube but i'm going
solaire is the sunlight guy
jolly cooperation
praise the sun
sorry i got carried away
go the dlc
do i have what i need to access the dlc
now i think
thank you anderson
uh
what's the best way to get there
uh
i did perish
yeah we went we went to the lake
i mean i did the whole archive area so
i'm assuming i got everything i need
dude this game requires you to remember
[ __ ]
so hardcore
check your key items
broken pendant
[Music]
i think that's what you said
so yeah
why am i going this way
it's so crazy to have to remember paths
i really like that about this game
if i could go to the undead berg that
would be easiest but you can't
like not
warp there immediately
oh my god my
we are vacuuming the living [ __ ] out of
the upstairs
yep
i'm going to the lake down there that's
my goal
can you get the black knight arm reset
in this game
i'm assuming so
that would be cool
yeah the the intense cleaning that is
done when guests are coming over
even though they don't care
all of them are shane
all of them
every single stream i've done on youtube
is also a video
in its own playlist
oh this was definitely the easiest way
to get here
yes shane
go back and watch them all
did your mom ask you to make your bed
no i'm literally that gamer that still
lives with their parents at 27 years old
in the basement i'm that guy
and honestly i love it
it's great
waterfall people out as [ __ ]
yeah no one's coming in the basement
dude for real
like the economy in this economy like
the
houses are so expensive
i could buy a house
i just
don't want to
with these [ __ ]
prices dude
so do i touch the creepy thing
oh my god the depth
i'm touching the creepy thing
hello chile how are you
i bet that's how we entered dlc and
elden ring whenever that comes out
i got so lucky shane
it was my first try
i just killed the black knight and there
it was
oh i should say i should rest here
mantis is latin for hand
well look at that
i just got the hand
what is this
oh sanctuary guard i just go right into
this huh
okay [ __ ]
whoa
what
i don't know i don't know the move set
here's a scorpion tail
ow
i i literally can't move
it takes me so long to get up
bro
what is that i'm so i can't [ __ ] do
anything
okay
looks so weird
okay
uh
um
okay
i should not have won that fight
like i was doing so bad
i legit couldn't move
i don't want the tail weapon we're just
gonna use this weapon
oh this looks nice here
[Music]
the it like spread through the water
that was kind of cool
um and i'm still not like
47
it does make my weapon a little bit
better but i'm gonna get a little bit
more health going
[ __ ] mushroom
oh
are you going to hurt me well look at
this one i love your voice what far away
age has thou come
thy scent is very human indeed but not
intolerable
princess dusk's saviour
this aura is precisely as she described
i thank thee deeply for rescuing her
highness oh the girl says dusk is here
no longer
snatched away by that horrifying
primeval human
and so i must ask
could there once more play the savior
yeah
thank you sure i am elizabeth
guardian of this sanctuary
something of a godmother to princess
dusk i shall assist thee to my utmost
for i am one with the sorceries of aura
seal
okay
gold fine resin
repair powder thanks
may the flames guide thee
now this isn't my first time it's just
been years since i've played this game
all right let's go
i think i i've only beaten this game one
time
it was
like four years ago
okay
she gives me shrooms
i do like shrooms
hello
okay
i wouldn't say i have any build in
particular actually
no no mods
i miss
the heck is that
nice
maddie what did that remind you of
so he joints that thing right back out
of there and i'm dead okay got it got it
okay
you should probably increase your estes
i mean
i don't want to use
humanities i've only found two
uh
do fire keeper souls
how high is my res
11. what does resistance do
i probably could have read it and would
have told me
but i'm a stupid idiot
see you come here
now you're dead
okay mr giant
stop
there we go
i think we're doing fine guys
this one's having a spasm
i think we're doing just fine
run get out of there
that attack is really cool though i
twinkled it
i don't need those anymore my weapon's
fully upgraded
am i going the right way
dude why do those look like little dicks
what the heck
on the side
this looks nice
okay that looks like a shortcut
eventually
guardian gauntlets
nice
okay
i want to get down there
clearly
kill the npc that looks like bloodborne
yeah i upgraded my armor once
i haven't touched it again though
okay
whoa
got some shroomy boys down here
oh those are these flowers
okay
these guys are hard to read
there we go
we'll see what we do
guardian leggings
is the guardian armor good
whoa
hi
whoa you look awesome
holy [ __ ] that was cool
that was [ __ ] awesome
like how he looked at me
that's calamity
what am i hearing right now
i figured it out
is there a storm
i literally opened my window to see if
it was storming outside
you guys hear that
i can't i literally am so confused is
that in game
i don't think so
oh what happened here what the [ __ ]
that isn't game
hi esther
so that's the abyss
gotcha
ow
he tried to shish about me
there's no other way of getting his drip
that's the abyss
they're trying to rake me like some
[ __ ] leaves dog
okay
am i going the right way
what are they doing
oh they're trimming the trees
die
this area is really cool
a gold queen
open the map lol
are the thunder sounds in game or am i
having a thunderstorm outside
i still can't tell
like that dodge right there you see that
use rivers of blood
oh shoot
owie mommy
[ __ ] you
that's spooky scary
ain't gonna cap on a stack with you
come here twinkle
okay
i think i'm gonna go this way
it's in game thunder thank you it's so
realistic i'm right next to my window
and it is cloudy outside so i didn't
know if that was here or not
oh
is this did i unlock it is this the one
i wanted
no it's up there
yeah i don't want to go in there yet i
would assume
that's a long trek
hello
oh yeah this guy screams bloodborne
ah let me guess
snatched by a shadowy limb and dragged
off to the past
uh
yep
yes of course exactly what happened to
me we are both strangers in this strange
land
but at least now they're a tool because
bloodborne stream this guy screamed the
sky
prevents estus recovery within a limited
area why the [ __ ] would i want that
did you happen across knight artorias
legendary abyss walker from the old
tales abyss walker if you haven't it's
just as well he's a colorless sort if
you ask me
should i kill him
all right do i kill him or no chat
it's got a lot of blood around
there's an item down there
it's a pvp okay
no
kill him
yes yes
he drops his arm
kill him okay
oh it's come to blows hazard
fine then oh he's tough as [ __ ]
oh i'm in trouble
uh-oh
he does so much damage
oh i [ __ ] up didn't it
no i thought he'd stagger he's so close
you damn fool i am marvelous chester
what did you expect
i like his voice actor
i should have gone to the shortcut first
dude
oh man
i should have come back
frigg
if i just stayed with i got so scared of
him dang it
that's been the case throughout this
entire game if i just stick with
somebody and keep hitting them
they die
i gotta go all the way around huh
this way
oh my god
you should go back later okay
run
and that lightning sound effect sounds
so [ __ ] realistic holy [ __ ]
a nice surprise
for me
just for me
that one's not that bad
stay
thank you
so is uh chester not gonna like me still
chester does not like me still
understandably so understandably so
ball
nice
he didn't die i'm getting the short
excellent
so now i'm assuming this works
[Music]
okay
where is he
just [ __ ] walking dog
okay i'll go down
i hate everything
any like quite literally anything but a
dog
anything but a dog and we're cool
but what do we got there
[Music]
okay
don't knock them off
this time
but at least we got the shortcut right
dude the dogs are way more annoying in
this game than they were in alderman
i'll tell you that
just their timing of attacks just [ __ ]
you over
i guess if i were a bandit and had
really quick attacks it wouldn't even be
that big
okay don't be mean
okay
is this all he has
why is he saying that
you win please
oh please
have mercy
he turned into a weenie
that armor looks really cool
is it good though
yeah actually
holy [ __ ]
okay i look [ __ ] awesome
i feel like i'm playing a mix of
bloodborne
should i okay should i go down or uh in
here
i'm gonna go in here
oh it's him dude
cool
he looks so cool holy [ __ ]
so he's an abyss watcher like the abyss
watchers in dark souls 3.
[Applause]
he just chucked someone at me
holy [ __ ]
okay we got delayed attacks
okay we're learning
ew
sprayed his goop on me
that attack is really [ __ ] cool
what's he doing
do you just puff
oops
okay
i i can't move
wow
he just staggered the living [ __ ] out of
me i couldn't move at all
wow okay i only had uh one essence
though so
that wasn't too bad
no i haven't heard the cut dialogue
you should have done this before sift
for dad's cutscene
oh
too late
hmm
he does need the ring but manus just
manhandled him and he left the ring with
sit
for you to find eventually by defeating
so
so he's just been taken over by the
abyss
he's like a good guy
also you can stop his buff if you whack
him two or three times okay
good to know
good to know
thank you for telling me that
now
i'm gonna go for a heal
sketch built
god damn
he delays like margaret
[ __ ]
dude if i get stuck in that i can't get
up
and he can still hit me while i'm down
holy [ __ ]
dang it
[Music]
that's why his arm is broke he protected
sif with the shield and broke his arm as
he was corrupted
that's why his arm is dangling
yeah is that just a straight up stun
lock like i'm just dead if i get hit
he's a hero
that's sad
he was sent to fight gwen he was sent by
gwen to fight the abyss of manus because
gwen feared it in order to do so
he made a pact with the dark raids
damn bro
i feel bad
are we like do are we pulling a radon
here or we're putting him out of his
misery type type thing
i can hear him breathing in here
totally like radon cool
sent me [ __ ] flying bro
god it takes an absolute hour to not be
staggered
and to heal
that didn't hit bro
[Music]
please no please not again
god
no
bro
i can't see
nope it's not worth is it
i wouldn't be able to get two hits in
oh i hit a midair
cool death
nice
that was close
holy [ __ ]
okay go this way
he is uh
definitely enter the gazebo what
purple cowards crystal
what is this
duel ruins
what is this
oh
plague of lead plaque of legends
nothing comes up okay
it's because i'm offline
oh this is a perfect area to do pvp
oh
80 000 souls for his armor
that's a lot
yeah it's like a yes perfect place for
pvp
what am i hearing right now
hello
hey that kills me
i'm gonna stick with this armor for now
that was the best boss fight in the game
though 100
his moveset was sick
like actually [ __ ] awesome
[Music]
uh is this a place i can warp to
i don't know what they're called [ __ ]
or actually let me level
can i use his soul
at the guardian soul oh i have a
humanity i can offer
should i use these
oracle township you can okay thanks
don't use his soul
okay
can i use the guardian soul
[Music]
i don't know who sir lane is that
i mean we got the weapon we want
use guardian souls since it can't be
used for a weapon
i can
[Music]
uh
what does resistance do
explanation
wrong button
boosting defense and resistance to pose
poison
you go back to the boss
arena
give her the soul and she will give you
her weapons that was her
that was her best
okay
i'll go back there
[Music]
it's just level five
let me
go back
township
guess we're gonna find out
[Music]
is shane's telling me to kill her
whoa she looks sick
hi tyranitor how are you
yeah we killed chester
shane's a forehead
is that not the soul of the man who fell
on this spot
he was a dear friend
i wish to pay proper respect with that
soul would you be willing to part with
it
uh
i don't want the abyss great sword i
have the best weapon in the game i'm
just going to give it to her
thank you
you are very kind
please take this
i no longer need it
may the lord guide thee
okay
little shrine may the lord guide thee
she looks awesome
all right
we're out of here
there's no other way to get your armor
okay calm down everyone calm down
jesus
uh
okay
do we want to go this way
let's do it
you made the biggest mistake i really
doubt that
i haven't played the dlc in a very long
time
was there only one dlc for dark souls
they fooled you i mean i trust metal
babe more than anybody else so
it doesn't open yet
there's only one that's very surprising
actually
am i hearing somebody scream
okay didn't think it would come in that
fast
excellent
hey oh somebody's behind me
now
you're dead
[Applause]
there are three and trust me they're
good i have heard the best thing about
dark souls 2 is the dlc
and i never even beat the main game so
we'll play the whole
play the whole thing after we beat this
game
bloodborne had one dlc too
knew it
didn't even look
very good carving
this area reminds me of uh lothric from
dark souls 3.
is this much harder than eldon ring i
wouldn't say
that's the case not really
i've died mostly from fall damage
a few times from bosses
i also have like a super insanely good
weapon so
here's some more abyss sludge
hello
[Applause]
giving her the soul equals getting her
weapons killing why are you still on
this we already did it
okay i think i need to drop down here
wait what's over here
not a finger
leave me alone
thank you
[Applause]
rigid outskirts no i don't know what
that is
oh
ow wow that hurt a lot holy
[ __ ] body's flying out everywhere
oh that's right i couldn't i didn't have
to drop down i'm an idiot
serious scary
single worst location in a video game
just all video games the worst one
okay
that guy's having a great day over there
i gotta sneeze
excuse me
nope never played codeman
am i going
wow
thank you miro
thank you dave thank you jet
thank you all let me go this way
ow my heart
hello
you'll have to let me know when we reach
the frigid outskirts
i hear a little girl screaming
and that's scary
oh this is the shortcut huh
i
see
okay
cool cool cool cool
it's the last area of the game
they [ __ ] up the last area
damn that sucks
unified calamite i don't know where
calamite is
uh excuse me
okay then
i'm not killing her i don't want to
oh i didn't rest
yeah i just got double bopped there huh
i mean sheesh
rest
let's go
bye bye
they gonna fall to their death
okay
let's try that again
fight
mantis with no weapon
i feel like that's not
oh they [ __ ] track okay
yup
okay
still hear a girl screaming
this area looks awesome
there are things whispering to me
i hear whispering
okay
is this guy chill
the [ __ ] is this
not chill
not not chill at all
i don't know what i'm looking at here
okay
i got killed by a narwhal
damn
[Music]
get annihilated jake my god
of course i fought my deer
i have like a thousand hours in dark
souls 3
but i've only beaten this game once
dark souls 3 was my first one
first souls game
this area
is hard
i don't know what she just did but i'm
scared
i think we have all the lord vessels
yeah
this guy is scary
i'm not a huge fan
okay
what is your favorite souls game
um i thought it was elden ring but i've
been reconsidering that recently
yeah we killed ons
uh two streams ago i think
what i was looking at chat and that
scared me
uh i think dark souls 3 might be my
favorite one
and it's probably just because it was my
first
i am level
75.
oh bonfire let's go
where am i going
area is scary guys
favorite souls boss
um
probably the abyss watchers
i think
music
uh overall like this fight in general
am i in the abyss right now like [ __ ]
dude
it's spooky scary well that answered my
[ __ ] question
okay that didn't hit excellent
gail is a great boss
but i think my favorites the abyss
watchers i just really like that fight a
lot
a one at a time one at a time
who is this
excellent
i'm the source of the abyss
but i'm nice
it doesn't seem nice here
are those humanities
are they gonna hurt me
i love how i answer my question
so often
excellent
excellent
floating metapods
is that manus
i think
can we kill manus with one flask
what's the best humanity farm
oh do i get humanities here
that would make sense
oh
[Music]
why would i unequip my weapon
oh never mind it's conan
okay
my character looks awesome right now
dude
it's the same hand from earlier
i missed a bunch okay i'll go back
if i can i'm sure i'm dead here
there's no shot i beat man his first try
i don't remember his moveset at all
good start
okay
okay
i'm still getting up when i get hit it's
kind of annoying
okay
that didn't go well
at all
excellent okay where do i farm the
humanities
oh almost fell okay uh
yeah where do i do that
just where all those floating humanities
were
all these dudes
save doggo
i don't
what dog
awesome
[Applause]
sif is down here
really
um
okay
probably need to kill which [ __ ] first
guys i killed sif two days ago
[Music]
oh we're in different time though right
okay where's sif
you guys are telling me to do like eight
different things right now
you want me to farm humanity do you want
me to
steve siff do you want me to fight manus
what do you want me to do
oh that helps
that doesn't
i'm not getting humanities from this
though
am i
if one of these little [ __ ] are gonna
kill me
okay
everything kills you so fast in this
area like you're just dead
instantaneously
[Music]
i have one humanity
don't get stuck thanks
gold serpent ring
covetous gold serpent ring
forehead just don't get stuck
you guys are great
he has a great
just love
i'm down here
i'm scared
okay there's one
ow
stop
[Applause]
i have no idea how many i've already
given to
the lady the spider lady
is there any way to check
there's another one
i got two right there
excellent
they were trying to save
solaire silver scarab amulet
you gave her 14
check the door
does the door tell you
okay
let's go back
i know it opens on 30.
got that covered
you'll know you need to give more if you
can't get through the door
true
very true
okay
is it possible to warp
here
like where are we right now
is it just called the abyss
probably
okay let's go daughter of chaos
we got
one twin
three more
offer
bye
[Music]
okay not enough obviously
door didn't tell you [ __ ]
11 more do we know that
dungeon
okay uh
can you buy them from somebody
you buy humanities
you gave her 14 and now five wouldn't
that make 21 and we need nine more
or no i'm stupid and can't count
yeah that's 11. my bad
my bad
i need to kill you
i'm down here
oh my god
dude i hate farming it's so boring
i should just be able to play the game
naturally
and get stuff that i need
there's one
potentially two
there's another one
okay that's three
um
yeah
yeah i don't want to do this this is
boring i'm gonna go check and see if uh
you guys said
patches does
and firelink
this is boring
[Music]
this patch is even here
i talked to him in the catacombs
they cost 10k
and i have these
[Music]
yeah yep
[Music]
they did look like cemetery shades
yeah i don't know how people farm
anything
it's so boring i don't want to farm i
want to try and be a manas
or do i have to save solaire before
manas
[Music]
oh yeah just throw on a podcast and
you're good
oops
go calamite okay where's calamity
was it where i fell
uh when fighting the guy i'm wearing the
armor for
[Music]
um
oh i could just go to the [ __ ]
yeah this is taking away from me
you need to see him first
then talk the cough
if you have the key to the tower i don't
know who cough is
but i did see calamine
off
golf or cough
[Music]
did she leave a flower
that's really nice
rip this guy
thank you pyro
mantis drops 10 humanity then why
wouldn't we try and kill mans
cal meets a side boss
still want to fight him
[Applause]
i'm just seeing what's over here calm
down
jesus people
tell me it gives you a ring that doubles
damage
sounds little
hey
that's sick
[Music]
doubles damage taken
this seems like a boss arena if i've
ever seen it
whoa oh [ __ ]
okay
so that's insta-death
that was insta death
okay
now what do i need
get the kres key
i don't know who go is
or where he is
okay where do i get the kres key
do i have the krusky
no no no
no
from a mimic
going from bonfire to the artorias area
a artorious area
passage
okay
cypher don't even attempt to be like
left or right bro
you're gonna miss it
you're gonna miss your window
oh i could have just walked down like
that instead of doing what i did before
that's a lot easier
going from the bonfire you started with
okay
i'll
go back there
oracle township
you pierced your ear that's cool
did you go to the mall
no i went up here and i couldn't open
the door
uh
okay
he is in the town
wait i killed a mimic
the mimic that was just sitting on top
of a roof i killed the mimic shouldn't i
have the key
let's go into town again
this is remastered
that's a difference
okay
okey-dokey
not that one
why is there a little girl screaming
this scares me
let me go this way
eat that body
no i experienced blighttown
before remastered
okay
bro yeah just spam your [ __ ] is that
it right there
no all right
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
i am not having a good time trying to
decipher what the [ __ ] you guys are
trying to say
[Music]
waffles
you guys are horrendous with directions
like horrible
[Music]
spammy nero bridge
no i'm good with directions as you say
left and right in a delayed chat
but yes waffles are better than pancakes
much better
so over there
you name my fault okay
how do i get up there i need to get on
that ledge
okay i think i need to go in here
somewhere
i do not know how to get up there
this looks like the right way
[Applause]
okay
i like that
okay
we did it
clap some chat for your horrible
directional skills
horrifying
what do i use it for again
[Applause]
nope
nope
that's right okay got it
this guy is just stuck to me
i don't like it
just bone out i'm right here
relax people
jump i kind of like it i like having a
friend
oh
let's see
name him he's gone now
you go
okay who the [ __ ] is this
holy bow
hello
hmm
that old friend he was
thanks to thee
he left this world with honor intact
and iran
retired
and blind
okay
uh
he doesn't sell humanities dragons
shall never be
forgotten
we knights fought valiantly
but for every one of them
we
[Music]
of our lost
exaggeration
pride
hatred
rage
the dragons teased out our dearest
emotions
thou will understand one day
without twilight
gold thoughts return
great waves of nostalgia
okay
i will i like him what was the point of
that though
it's cool
keep talking
okay
i feel like that was the end of that
conversation but okay
ask him about
dragon calamity the jurors
yes
yes
i thought as much
he's called calamite
ferocious
dared not provoke his eye
i see little good coming from this
but
my intent is to persevere
to the bitter
end yeah
[Laughter]
good good
what is bravery without a dash of
recklessness
i've taken a liking to thee nice
for thy service to artorias
now
watch
and see how golf hunts dragons
ooh
[Music]
cool
he legit can't see
[Music]
how does he
oh my god
okay well calamity is [ __ ] dead
yes
a true shot was never loosed
that bat will be grounded for a good
spell
the rest is in thine hands oh he's not
dead
bro he is badass
there he is an ancient dragon
sky but i know
he will not be put down easily
i wouldn't think so
i okay good tidings
so when i kill him should i come back
and tell him
yeah how
you know what i'm not gonna question it
i think he's just a legend with a bow
i was gonna say how the [ __ ]
did he notice did he even know where
calamie was
so now i go the way i went before huh
okay
um
okay
give you his bow
wow
i mean i won't use it but that's neat
let's go this way
giants are humble i really like him
he seems lit
that doggy
he's pretending to be blind
that's what it looks like
considering he just sniped the dragon
from miles away blind
holy [ __ ] i hate dogs
in game in in-game dogs are great
i love dogs
gala meet
where are you
didn't he get sniped
like down
here should have kindled well i have to
save the [ __ ] humanities for the
other thing you guys want me to do
oh here we go
oh there you are
the lock-on's quite bad
okay
we gotta run away from that
can i get up please
nope
why is my character not running can i
not run when i'm locked on
what
all right
i'm dead
all right we're learning
the move set
he just he just pissed off he's like all
right
i killed this little
[Music]
ant all right whatever i will uh kindle
this [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] it
yep just took out the
just took out the arrow huh
albert only run no it's just a really
good weapon
so
i'm using it
please lower the sound effect volume so
we can enjoy the music
i guess i can i haven't touched it for
the rest of the game though
i know it's like really quiet
just built different he had a lot of
moves man
a lot of moves
music should have been to ten i mean i
would like to hear myself
you guys are very demanding today
okay i'll do whatever you want
so
what
that was terrifying
what is on my head
that was a lot easier the second time
though that music is really good
what does the calamity ring
do okay this is dead people
a dragon high above the sky out of sight
of the naked eye
not anymore
we already beat four kings like
two hours ago
oh a slabby
boy ah the music is great
i'd say the fight was really easy or i
just got really really really good rng
see what this is first
bum bum
only hawkeye
goes great arrow
okay
should i just bone her out of
here yeah i got four
[Music]
should i go talk to go
uh can i use any of these
by the way
right which boosts bonfires even further
why have we not used that
anyway
actually i can't use them i'm just
looking at the wrong thingy
just like that you killed one of the
strongest beans in the universe
so nothing can pop it possibly stop us
now right
besides manus
who's stronger calamite or mantis
points to front
oh yeah we could do that
manus
well i don't mean like in difficulty but
like in in the universe who would kill
who
i has defeated calamite wondrously
played
lord quinn's blessing upon me
that beast
will never take to the skies again
[Music]
farewell proud human
may every honor be bestowed upon thee
thanks man
i did not
or do i just keep talking to him to get
his bow
against again
it is always
always an
honor here we go this great move
i shall need it but no dragons to hunt
i know not of a human could even operate
it
but here
i need outweighs mine
cool
we got it
[Music]
nice
oh [ __ ]
manus over calamite or equal to
okay is that the next goal
is to kill manus
or i forget what we said earlier do we
have to save
solaire first
man is the insular
okay i will try to kill manus
that's probably the last thing i can do
for today
it is
i should kindle this you mean
probably
oh i can't excellent
menace i'm saying manus
what
i've been saying manus the entire time
excuse me excuse me excuse me
okay
[Applause]
have i not been saying manus the entire
time
i've quite literally never called a
menace
oh ripsieve
[Music]
now
guess we can save stuff now
[Music]
yeah where is he
do you like this way
so much
[Applause]
dark deed
why these guys get stuck on me all the
time
that's where we're going before
there's got to be more over here right
so there's an illusionary wall
getting the feeling that it's not over
here
there are more
to go over here
nope shut
am i in the right area over here
how would you know
it's down okay that would have been nice
what the heck is that
oh
it's a cat
[Music]
i'm scared
okay
why does the cat want to help save the
doggie or do is the cat holding the dog
that's a big humanity
can't hit it
yes i can
sieve
it's the royal wood
okay that's a nice shortcut
good to know
bob ross is humanity
it's a big one
so
something
oops
okay we'll go back
just seeing what was down here
here
baby
what
the baby ones are harder than the big
ones
oh it really is stiff
[Music]
cool
cleansing great shield is that uh
artorias's shield before
his arm got broke
cool
that's awesome
cool little area
just another way to get down here
his shield can protect from the power of
the abyss
so what you're saying is i should use
that
against
menace
i guess this isn't
a shortcut
silver pendant
i
don't know
i have a broken pendant
i'm just gonna do it like this
oh i can't get back up there
is there somewhere i can go over here
this is weird
this would be here
got it
that's where this lady is
okay let's try to kill manus
i'm
upset about that
i really am
that one hurt the soul
i picked
help me carving
oh god
oh i'm [ __ ]
take a leap of faith
i don't even know where i am now i went
the wrong way
yeah i kind of know where i am now
gravity the true final boss you are
not wrong on that one when it comes to
me
i have definitely fallen to my death
more than i've died to bosses in this
game for sure
i will say it's hard to play these games
in stream
probably a big part of it
all right time to get slapped around a
bit
awesome
[Music]
so didn't have gone for a hit all right
this one's gonna be hard
okay
i'm glad i saw that attack
[Music]
before we died
ready to go get dogs oh [ __ ]
i really want to beat this boss before i
get off
do we do that tomorrow
i think i gotta go i gotta pick up the
dogs from
they got bads and a nail trim
it blocks that
is it rollable
let me try one more time
can we see him
you see those red things down there is
that him
looks like it
[Music]
that's three
okay
[Music]
oh my god
what the
that's ridiculous
i tried i tried rolling it
didn't work very well
probably because i mistimed it
i'm dead
yeah
yep we're gonna we're gonna do this
tomorrow
i gotta go get the dogs
they're at the kennel
i gotta pick them up anyway
thanks for being here boys
appreciate the help we'll come back
tomorrow we might be able to finish the
game tomorrow or
actually i don't know if i can even
stream tomorrow um
if i can't stream tomorrow then i won't
be on again until monday so we'll see
next time we pick it up
i think we can beat the game
i think we're gonna see anyway
you all have a great rest of your day
thank you again for being here go check
out everything in the description i
appreciate it appreciate it if you did
other than that